the newest season of stranger things
looks to be the strangest and darkest
yet have you been california dreaming of
when it will drop curious if david
harbour will be returning as hopper
watch this before you see stranger
things season 4 part 1.
unlike previous seasons of stranger
things season 4 of the show's release
pattern will work a little differently
instead of releasing it all at once
season 4 will be released in two
separate parts part 1 were released on
may 27th while part 2 were released just
5 weeks later on july 1st the release
strategy seems poised to ensure that
stranger things will once again be an
event viewing of the summer similar to
how season 3 was when it came out in
2019 according to the duffer brothers
the main reason behind this method of
release is that season 4 will be much
much longer than previous seasons of the
show
unsurprisingly most of the cast that
appeared in the first three seasons of
stranger things will once again be
making their return for season 4.
intriguingly some of the returning
actors include characters that seem to
meet their ends in previous seasons
david harbour is returning as jim hopper
after seemingly dying in the season 3
finale and he won't be the only
character returning after an uncertain
fate either after his apparent demise in
season one matthew modine's martin
brenner is also making his return to
stranger things though it's unclear in
what capacity
as with every new season stranger things
season 4 will feature some fresh faces
miles truett is joining the cast as
patrick a hawkins basketball player amy
beth mcnulty will appear as vicki regina
ting chen will play the role of guidance
counselor miss kelly grace van dien also
joins the dynamite cast as hawkins high
cheerleader chrissy and as announced in
november 2020 on instagram robert
englund who infamously played freddy
krueger will join the cast as victor
creel needless to say a lot of new
talent is joining the latest season of
stranger things and we can't wait to see
them all shine on the screen
until the first batch of season 4
episodes arrive events and storylines
remain up for debate that said the
official synopsis has been unveiled by
netflix and audiences are in for a real
treat according to netflix it's been six
months since the battle of star courts
which brought terror and destruction to
hawkins struggling with the aftermath
our group of friends are separated for
the first time and navigating the
complexities of high school hasn't made
things any easier in this most
vulnerable time a new and horrifying
supernatural threat surfaces presenting
a gruesome mystery that if solved might
finally put an end to the horrors of the
upside down as more seasoned audience
members can probably recall high school
comes with its own batch of trials and
tribulations so it'll be interesting to
see how the characters handle life in
the big leagues while dealing with the
madness of the upside down season 3
ended with what looked like hopper and
billy's deaths these events led to joyce
will jonathan and eleven packing their
bags and leaving behind the tainted
memories of hawkins eleven also seems to
have lost her powers to boots what will
then fold remains anyone's guess but if
the synopsis is any indication fans will
be in store for a wild ride in another
horror-like setting what's not to love
about that
look like a million bucks yeah and
you're gonna slam dead like a lion
in an interview on the podcast present
company with christa smith the duffer
brothers hinted at a darker horror movie
vibe for season four if that were even
possible given the events of season
three ross duffer explained how the
series had evolved over the previous
seasons stating when we pitched it to
netflix all those years ago we pitched
it as the kids are the goonies in e.t
that's their storyline that depiction
was initially in contrast to the
atmosphere that older characters
encountered ross continued the adults
are in jaws and close encounters and
then the teens are in nightmare on elm
street or halloween but this year we
don't have the kids we can't do the
goonies anymore and so suddenly we're
leaning much harder into the horror
movie territory that we love now that
the kids are grown up at least in real
life that is gravitating towards the
horror elements of the series sounds
like a delightfully sinister idea
creating a tv series especially one
revolving around child actors isn't easy
that really rings true and the show
isn't only intended for younger
audiences not only did this factor make
it difficult to get stranger things
greenlit but it also meant that the
child actors at the center of their
story would inevitably age out of their
roles this aspect can at times be
painfully obvious suffice it to say the
children actors on stranger things are
no longer kids in a 2017 interview with
the hollywood reporter creators matt and
ross duffer were asked if the kids
ageing put pressure on them to work at a
certain pace ross said it's better to
adjust the narrative to fit the ages
than to try to rush the process
matt added that even if i had the choice
to freeze them in time i wouldn't we
don't want to be repeating ourselves
this show is going to naturally evolve
and feel different year to year and that
to me is a good thing
jim hopper is a complicated character
who quickly became a fan favorite in
season one he's a hero of the town and
in a way a father figure to not just the
children of the series but the
townspeople as well however if the
season 3 finale is any indication the
fictional town won't have its rock for
the foreseeable future as he appeared to
have met his demise luckily appearances
can be deceiving as hopper has already
been shown in a trailer for the upcoming
season alive with a shaved head and in
russia if hopper has a pulse he's likely
going to cause some damage to the bad
guys at some point despite being
imprisoned in russia
billy was in pretty bad shape at the end
of season 3. not only did the mind
player control him all season but he
went head to head with the upside down
creature and last in a tragic scene his
sister max witnesses his demise however
in a genuinely heroic turn of events
billy who had been a villain ever since
his introduction to the series switches
teams and saves 11. many viewers
rightfully hope he's still alive as he
brings bravado not to mention a truly
amazing mullet to the screen but getting
stabbed multiple times by a creature as
lethal as the mind flayer is likely
fatal it wouldn't be out of the question
for the russians who have taken him but
that's based purely on speculation fan
theories and leaps of faith aside
viewers will have to wait for the fourth
season to arrive to find out if billy
really is dead although we're not
holding our breath you are so dead
sinclair
you're dead
no
you are
as audience members have come to know
and love stranger things tends to split
its cast up with each group trying to
solve its own mystery although they
often eventually meet up in an epic
finale as for season four the characters
will be scattered across four different
locations netflix has already announced
the characters will have to face the
events of season four apart from each
other as our heroes will find themselves
in russia the creel house the lab and
california it remains to be seen what
each group of characters will face but
fans can be sure that each location will
have its share of dark and deadly
challenges given that the characters are
spread out all across the globe it will
be interesting to see how exactly they
all meets up in the end
for stranger things fans who are having
a tough time waiting for may 27th to
arrive there are a few glimpses of what
the next season of the show will hold
one teaser trailer focuses mainly on 11
and her adjustment to a new life in
california it is narrated by 11 in the
form of a letter to mike wheeler though
the text of the letter is far more
hopeful and positive than what the
audience has shown meanwhile in a teaser
trailer titled 11 are you listening a
man who appears to be dr martin brenner
aka popper walks through a hallway and
speaks to a group of children who
presumably have powers similar to 11.
good morning children
how are you today
good
the camera eventually makes its way to a
door with 11 on it and papa asks 11 are
you listening a spooked 11 opens her
eyes it remains to be seen if this is a
flashback featuring previously
unreleased information or if the doctor
is up to his old tricks in the present
day another sneak peek trailer released
in the summer of 2021 shows a series of
seemingly random events from previous
seasons of stranger things intercut with
clips from season four there's also a
trailer titled creole house which
features a happy family moving into our
house before unexplainable supernatural
events begin to terrorize the family
flash forward to the present where we
see some of the mainstay characters of
stranger things enter a beaten up and
abandoned house looking for mysterious
clues which may lead them to the upside
down
though season 4 will be split into two
parts netflix was kind enough to reveal
all nine episode titles for the upcoming
season in the title tease trailer they
are the hellfire club veganist curse the
monster and the superhero dear billy the
nina project the dive the massacre at
hawkins lab popper and the piggyback
despite all the titles being intriguing
it's interesting that episode 4 is
titled dear billy since he's presumed
dead that said it's not out to the
question but some flashback scenes have
believed to occur though that's based on
speculation of course popper is the name
of the doctor who raced 11 and the
viewers were already gifted with a
teaser trailer featuring the mad
scientist as to what the rest of the
episode titles might refer to fans are
already combing through the show for
clues
the world is full of obvious things
which nobody by any chance ever observes
there's good and bad news here first and
foremost no this isn't the last season
of stranger things however season 5 is
scheduled to conclude the upside down
saga in a 2022 interview with scream
rant sean levy gave his reasons for the
show's inevitable ending we wanted to
only tell as much story as the brothers
saw and feel with clarity it's been
clear for a while that they know exactly
where we're headed and this is the ark
we wouldn't want to stick around for one
moment beyond that vision and the
clarity of that voice it's not easy
saying bye to this uber popular series
but characters like 11 hopper and the
rest of the stranger things family
deserve a happy ending they have by all
standards been through an awful lot with
that said the duffer brothers teased
other stories to tell in the stranger
things universe in an open letter to
fans shared by netflix perhaps spin-off
or films will be on the horizon
as mentioned in the duffer brothers
letter shared by netflix they might be
ending the series after five seasons but
that doesn't necessarily mean the
franchise is coming to an end if
anything it sounds like this is just the
beginning although repeating the success
creativity and intrigue of the inaugural
series will take some magic the letter
said in part there are still many more
exciting stories to tell within the
world of stranger things new mysteries
new adventures new unexpected heroes but
first we hope you stay with us as we
finish this tale of a powerful girl
named eleven and her brave friends of a
broken police chief and a ferocious mom
of a small town called hawkins and an
alternate dimension known only as the
upside down as always we are grateful
for your patience and support season 4
isn't the end and if this letter is any
indicator perhaps other stories in this
universe will eventually make their way
to the masses volume 1 will hit netflix
on may 27th and volume 2 will be
released shortly after on july 1st
season 4 is almost upon us and we can't
wait to see what's in store
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite television shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]